99.
[Silence]
I'm going to see
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Yesterday morning we discussed the
how the companions
dealt with that.
Two important points
before we move on from that. Number
one, the kafar becomes obligatory
once the sun rises
on the day or once the break of dawn on
the day that a person is supposed to
fast. So the night before it is not
obligatory. It becomes obligatory once
the person experiences the break of dawn
of the day of Ramadan.
Then the person will u
do the kaf not before. Second of all a
good question that was asked was do we
do the kafar each day as we miss that
day or can we do it all together at the
end of the month and the answer is
either is correct. Here we have the
narration of anis
that he did it at the end at the end of
Ramadan he gathered 30 poor people
and he fed them all a meal of right how
do you know that the month is going to
be 30 days well you wouldn't know until
the month is over and so if it is 30
days or 29 days or if the person misses
10 or 15 days if the person were to
hypothetically pass away during Ramadan,
the kafar would only be for whatever had
passed of the days that he experienced
up until his death.
So every
act of worship has pillars. Every act of
worship has conditions. Every act of
worship has obligations.
We've discussed these things before.
Every act of worship has
conditions, pillars and obligations.
Every act of worship. So for instance,
what is the greatest act of worship a
person can do?
Right? Soahill
does it have conditions?
Yes. How many conditions does it have?
Who knows?
Two. Nope.
One.
Nope.
Seven conditions.
Seven conditions. Meaning these seven
things have to be all together
simultaneous
in order forahill to be accepted from a
person.
Is that not frightening? If you hear
that, a little tin should go up your
spine.
Because if you've never heard of this,
how do you know that you've fulfilled
all seven conditions? What are those
seven conditions?
Will not be accepted from a person who
fulfills six conditions.
It has to be all seven at the same time.
Soaha
has seven conditions
andahill
has how many pillars?
Two. Two pillars.
And how many obligations?
Many. All of the obligations of Islam
fall into the generalities of that.
But there are seven conditions
and two pillars.
How many conditions for salah?
This one I won't give you a pass because
I we mention I talked about this before.
14.
Nine conditions.
Nine conditions. How many pillars
of salah?
Go ahead. This is your This is your time
to shine. 14. 14 pillars.
And how many obligations of salah?
One more. Eight. Eight obligations for
salah,
etc., etc., right?
Fasting
has conditions. It has pillars. It has
obligations. What is a condition? What
is a pillar? We've mentioned this so
many times, but it warrants
repeating.
Conditions and pillars are the same
thing. They're the same thing. However,
conditions
are outside of the act of worship
itself. pillars are actually part of the
act of worship itself.
So for instance, a condition would be
the time for salah. The time for salah
has to be in. That's one of the
conditions,
but it's not actually part of the
prayer. A pillar rur is a pillar.
It's actually part of the of the act of
worship. Right? So conditions and
pillars they are the same thing in the
sense that if any of them are missing
the act of worship is it is invalid
whether a person forgets it or doesn't
it's invalid.
Obligation
is the same as pillars and conditions
only there is some wiggle room for a
person who forgets.
If you forget an obligation,
it doesn't invalidate the act of
worship. So an obligation, if you leave
it off on purpose, the act of worship is
invalid. But if you forget it, the act
of worship is still valid, right? Like
for instance saying
if a person were to forget it or to say
in its place and then stand for or for
instance the first
stand up and forget the first. This is
an obligation
which means that once you complete the
salah you can make sujud
and it will make up for it. But if a
person says well I'm kind of strapped
for time and let me not make the first
the salah is invalid. We understand.
Okay. So conditions
for instance to simplify it we
could say woo is a condition. Woo is
actually not a condition.
It's broader than woo. Okay. But to
simplify let's say woo is a condition of
salah. If I forgot to make wudoo and I
prayed would my prayer be valid?
No. and I remembered later. Do I have to
make it up? Yes. Even if I remember
after 10 years, I have to make that
prayer up again
because it is a condition. And if you
forget a condition, it still invalidates
the act of worship. Okay? Rur is a
pillar. If I forget to make rur
is my salah valid?
If I forget to make, is my salah valid?
No. No, it's not. How could it be? It's
a pillar,
right? It's a pillar. My salah is not
valid or at least that
is not valid. The entire is is invalid.
I have to make that one up. Now, saying
subur
that's an obligation.
If I were to forget it, is my salah
still valid?
The first of a salah that has twohood.
If I forget the first one, is my salah
still valid? Yes. If I leave it off on
purpose, is my salah still valid? No. Do
we understand now? Conditions,
pillars,
obligations.
Conditions, pillars, obligations.
So now with
and I kind of I kind of feel a little
bit bad because
the conditions
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
we said are how many seven and we said
the pillars ofahill are how many two and
we said the obligations
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
are many and I feel a little bad because
I'm supposed to be teaching that And I
have not taught you that yet. So we
haven't discussed that yet. You might
get a little tiny pass for that.
However, we will inshallah
discuss this after Ramadan. Big plans
for after Ramadan. Right, President? So
for fasting, it has conditions, it
has pillars, it has obligations.
Fasting has two conditions.
Two conditions.
The first condition is or fasting,
excuse me, fasting has conditions. We
mentioned those conditions in the
previous chapters, right? Muslim
alim,
right? Five conditions, right? that a
person for to make fasting obligatory
upon a person and we mentioned for the
female is an additional that she is
right too that she is free of
ministration or postpartum bleeding
those are the conditions we discussed
all that pillars of fasting are two two
pillars to fasting two
number one intention
number two refraining from anything that
breaks your fast. That's it. So, you'll
you'll come to realize that a lot of
times we already do that. We just
haven't categorize them in our minds
yet, right? But we all already do that.
We have the intention. We have But when
we are when we put a name and a
categorization to each of these rulings,
now we are worshiping Allah upon
knowledge.
Right? Now I can be sure that I have met
the criteria. Now when I have something
happen, I can pretty much understand
what needs to be done. Whether I need to
make the day up or whether I need to
continue fasting or whether I This is
why we learn these things, conditions,
obligations, pillars, right? Fasting has
two pillars.
Fasting has two pillars.
Number one, intention.
Number two, refraining from anything
that breaks a person's fast.
Pretty simple
intention.
For an obligatory fast, Ramadan or any
other fast that's obligatory,
you have to have the intention before
the break of dawn.
You have to have the intention
before the break of dawn.
Even if it is a conditional intention.
What is a conditional intention? Let's
say I got to wake up and go to work at
whatever, right? And so I go to sleep
before it's confirmed that tomorrow is
Ramadan. But tomorrow might be Ramadan.
So I go to sleep with the intention that
if tomorrow is Ramadan, I'm fasting.
Right? This is valid. This is correct.
But a person must have the intention to
fast before the break of dawn.
That and see the the question now is
does a person have to make that
intention consciously every day? That's
better. But if a person just has a
general intention that I'm going to fast
Ramadan this year and then proceeds to
do so, that's enough. That's what's
needed. So having a general intention
for the entirety of the month is enough.
But if a person
were to
have the individual intention every
single morning before the break of dawn,
that's better and that's more complete.
Right now, intention is not something
that you have to speak. Intentions are
beyond words.
You don't have to stand and make a
declaration of your intention to fast. I
hereby
intend to fast today from the break of
dawn until the sun sets. And I'm going
to fast for the sake of Allah. And I'm
going to this is unnecessary. The
prophet never did this. Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. His companions never
did this. If I came on anybody while
they were eating and I said, "What are
you planning to do?" Say, "Well,
obviously I'm eating sahur because
you know I'm going to fast." Most
people don't wake up before the break of
dawn to eat breakfast, right? That's not
a normal thing that that comes with
intentionality.
So the person has the intention to fast
already. The intention is already there.
A person sets his alarm to wake up for
they've already had the intention to
fast. That's exactly what the intention
is. And that goes for all acts of
worship. Salah included.
When I was a child, the way they, you
know, the elders taught us to pray
was that when you stand to make salah,
you have to stand and face the you say
blah blah blah. I I intend to
pray behind this im facing the fork for
the Lord with the intention of it being
up. The only thing left is to add the
address and zip code and phone number,
email address. This is unnecessary.
As soon as a person puts his shoes on to
go to the masjid, he already has the
intention to pray. Another good question
is what if I stand and as I'm making my
declaration of prayer of intention to
pray instead of saying I say by accident
I start praying
and it's time is my prayer invalid.
So my tongue said something that my
intention didn't intend. Therefore which
one? That means what you say has nothing
to do with your intentions.
An intention is never declared. Even in
Omra, you know in Omrah when we go for
or
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam teaches
us we are to say
right.
This is not a proclamation of intention.
This is a proclamation of the start of
your journey of
just when I stand to make I
begin with
this is my initiating
for form
it is the same thing when I make that
declaration.
This is not a declaration of intention.
This is a declaration of starting.
Right? Because the intention for Omra
isn't made at that moment, is it? The
intention for Haj and Omrah is usually
made months in advance, maybe even years
in advance. As soon as you start
shopping for Hajj packages, you've
already made the intention to make Hajj.
As soon as you begin buying things for
your journey, you've already had the
intention to make Hajj, right? Months
before you even begin your journey to
Hajj. So there's no instance where we
make a declaration of our intention.
And I'll give you an additional nugget
here. All four ims of the four all four
of them Abu Hanifh Maliki
Ahmed
along with Abu Hanifh's four other
companions that make up his med.
Remember we mentioned the
is
founded by Abu Hanifh
but it is it was solidified and built
by him and four other of his students.
Right? So all four of these imams along
with their prominent students, none of
them have ever even mentioned that it is
preferable for a person to ever proclaim
his intention.
None of them. Now the later students and
scholars of these med they mention these
things in their books. So after the
4th century some of the of the of the
started to posit that well it's
preferred that a person you know say
his intention because the tongue
you know helps to quantify the intention
etc etc. But this never came from the
four imams themselves
nor any of their known works. This came
from scholars that came way later that
were ascribed to their mahib.
So none of the companions, none of the
four imams of the Madib or the seven
before them which the four are comprised
of, nor even the
which is a fifth m
the m of hadith in the earlier
centuries of Islam. Had they ever even
preferred that a person say his
intention? Intentions are in the heart.
Right? Intentions are in the heart. And
some of the scholars have said if Allah
had commanded us to do anything without
an intention, he would have commanded us
to do something physically impossible
for us. It's impossible. It's impossible
to do something without an intention.
Right? And as far as acts of worship go
and this is what differentiates sane
from insane. Remember we mention what is
meant by insanity and what is meant by
sanity in the terminology in the
language of the fahab. It is the ability
to hold a coherent intention.
This is what differentiates the sane
from the insane. Correct. Therefore, the
first pillar of fasting is what?
The first pillar of fasting
intention. The second pillar of fasting,
refraining from anything that breaks
your fast. And tomorrow,
we will discuss
the six things that break a person's
fast. Six things. Anything outside of
this six things, it will not break your
fast.
Sheh, I got a I got a lidocaine
injection because I went to the dentist.
Does it break my fast? No. She my arm
got cut off and I was bleeding. Does it
break my fast? No. She I use a
suppository. Does that break my fast?
No. She I got cupping or blood drawn or
I got I got insulin shots. Does that
break my fast? No. These six things, we
will discuss them tomorrow. Anything
outside of these six things does not
break your fast. Inshallah.
[Silence]
Glad you're back.